et je le dis maintenant parce que
benjamin c'est vraiment maintenant c'est
moi non mais c'est mon frère je
considère vers l époque on s'aimait pas
vraiment je le considère vraiment comme
mon frère il le sait que je vois là je
serai toujours là pour lui et que je
laime vraiment énormément et c'est vrai
que je me rappelle d'un jour où j'avais
un playboy la mcafee va
jamais insulté au téléphone je viens ici
je te croise je me bats je vais te
casser peut-être
il se fait tuer n'est pas jouer au foot
j'y tiens je viens de chaval d eelv et
pourquoi tu défends ce tocard mais la
peur mais si vous ne le pensez même pas
mais il épiait ce que je faisais et
avant n'était pas tu étais pas très
connu moi j'avais un beau blouson cuir
grandes marques d'équipé poteau pour le
love extrait avec salut vient après
c'est quoi ce qu'on accepte vous emmerde
tout bon le cuir toit
s'est monté tout seul c'est fait vous
désabonner de nombreux dans votre tête
c'est vrai j'ai besoin d'aidé je pouvais
pas
mais autant je pouvais autant balckberry
comme maintenant je lève donc pour vous
dire à quel coût moi j'irai lui dit il a
commencé en disant que ça va pas bien
commencé entre nous benjamin je connais
depuis des années des années évidemment
je trouve que c'est un des mecs tu as
plein de des fautes avec plein d faute à
une boule à retenter jeu qu'on n'a pas
vu pascal et moi d'hélicoptères les
machins on n'a pas concédé face à
lille avec côté star et fils fils de ma
chance vient pas simple bien sûr ils
étaient bling mais mais mais mais depuis
je les ai vus chez la nuit on ajoute au
caire plein de fois dépassé on s'est
vraiment vu car vous aussi de les
mépriser
savait qu'on aurait pu devenir père et
gris etc est absolument non mais
tu as bien compris que mon filtre à moi
c'est les gens qui ont été et qui sont
dans l'erreur ce que j'espère je ne suis
pas un
gamin c'est un vraiment je vous dis
c'est un des mecs les plus fiables et
plus gentils et les que je connais tu
vois là je sais que je l'aimais vraiment
et et sa main dans la main je te jure en
fait en fait non mesquer non mais c'est
pas ça parce qu'avant quand tu te voyais
avec tes lunettes on vous enfuir avec
avec tam n'a fait qu'user mais nous
avons dit m
et on va t'il est tellement pas ça c'est
ça l'histoire c'est qu'il n'est
tellement pas savoir qui c'était ces
faits ont boudé par le système je te
jure ça bien sûr
il est à sa place lorsque tu deviendras
et west ham seraient plus grands si la
tête a atteint un niveau qui fait que
même la soulte est là il est trop belle
pour toi là tu es tranquille mais t'aime
tellement
comme monture est le truc je suis pas
sûr que tu lui reste
je vais vous dire sur sa réponse notre
série de vous dire un truc je pense que
cyril site peut se passer de l'antenne
ce qui est extrêmement rare au lendemain
il remontera des business à les fraudes
chose du paddle race être un dépanneur
je vais te dire la chance que j'ai eue
je te jure laurent et je dis aux
téléspectateurs tous ici à quelques mois
en fait j'ai connu une traversée du
désert avant même d'arriver dans le
désert
non mais c'est à dire que c'est vrai
c'est en fait quand moi j'ai connu dix
ont compliqué et en fait c'est ça donc
bref j'ai fait une carrière à pas lents
v12 cauet ou deux odinga est un peu
comme tout le monde d'ailleurs parce
qu'on a tous fait à l'envers en fait